an ax-wielding black man who said Asian
UC Berkeley students on fire with a
blowtorch
all right that's too hot we'll face no
jail time this is a man who was found
guilty so it's not even that he's just
being accused he was found guilty of
lighting UC Berkeley students on fire
inside a boba tea shop in 2020 with a
blowtorch he has been released from
custody he will avoid jail time his name
is Brandon McGlone 49 years old he's
going to participate in a diversion
treatment as part of his plea deal why
did Alameda County Superior Court give
him this sweet deal well because the
Alameda County district attorney Pamela
price ran on racial equity and you see
the man who was wielding the acts and
threatening people and setting students
on fire he's a black guy and his victims
were not black and so if you run on
platform explicitly of giving black
people leniency in the criminal justice
system going harder relatively on
everybody else and that's the sort of
thing you're going to get